peter i think you summarized it
perfectly earlier in the program when
you identified the four that we believe
are are likely most likely to join the
packers and the browns as teams with
vacancies the jets with todd bowles the
broncos with vance joseph the bucks with
dirk cutter and the cardinals with steve
wilkes i think it would be a surprise if
any of those four coaches aren't fired
beyond that we know there'll be more
just good luck figuring out which ones
they're going to be
well and and you know
the ones that are close and the ones we
really don't know
uh
you know let's take carolina for
instance
you can sit here i can sit here and say
this team's three years removed from
being fifteen and one ron rivera has not
lost control of this team
at all
and you shouldn't fire the coach
but again
we don't know what is going through a
new owner's head even though
his whole training for this job has
essentially been
to stay the course and because he knows
that that is how successful franchises
exist and how they keep going mike one
month from today
excuse me one month from today will be
the 50 year anniversary
of the hiring of chuck noll
and so you look at that you say
okay there's been a half century
in pittsburgh with three head coaches
and you can say whatever you want ah
tomlin's not good enough he can't get
today hey you know
the pittsburgh steelers every year
walk into training camp in latrobe
pennsylvania with a chance to win and a
chance to win big that is what a good
coach does he gets your team ready and
prepared to play a long season and to be
in contention at the end
to to get ready to win chuck noll did
that bill coward did that and now mike
tomlin is doing that and i only bring up
that point because it can seem to a new
owner man there's this guy out there
there's that guy i wonder what josh
mcdaniels could do maybe we could go and
get lincoln riley maybe this guy would
be who knows
but
i'll never forget the time covering the
giants
in the mid 80s
there was a punt returner there
named phil mcconkey
who got traded to the green bay packers
who at the time stunk and he was all
excited because he was going to get to
play in the regular offense as well as
being a punt returner he ends up getting
cut by the packers and coming back to
the giants and his quote to us in the
locker room when he came back to new
york was grass is greener my ass
[Laughter]
at this point at this point i hope that
david tepper kind of realizes that that
okay if you get nick saban that'll be
okay
but otherwise hang on to ron rivera and
keep going forward well and that's the
challenge peter and i think that's why a
lot of these guys may get another year
because it's the devil you know versus
the devil you don't and how are you
going to be confident you're going to
upgrade point i was kind of making with
the browns earlier now that greg
williams got him this to the point where
they're very good you better get
somebody who's really and clearly better
before you cut bait on greg williams and
so i think some of these guys who are on
the bubble maybe they stay because there
isn't that significant upgrade i want to
start in miami because i've heard from
several different people that stephen
ross would love to hire john harbaugh if
he could but now that the ravens have
made it clear that he's staying or at
least he's under contract through 2019
which i think is an invitation to
contact the ravens and make them an
offer unless steven ross is going to do
something like that and i've heard the
ravens are going to have a stiff asking
price if and when someone does call he's
just going to have to stick with adam
gase
here's the interesting thing about
harbaugh right now
so john harbaugh as you said is under
contract through 2019
and there have been a couple of
scenarios floated out there
one that his daughter is going to be a
senior in high school
and he would really love to get through
this next year with a solid family life
in the baltimore area and then after
that who knows
um
but i'm not sure that that's really
all that significant in terms of his
long-term future this is just what i
believe
i believe that john harbaugh
he would love to continue coaching the
ravens for a long time but there's a
couple of things at play here
if you're dick cass the president of the
ravens if you're steve bisciotti the
owner of the ravens you look at your
team since you won the super bowl you're
50 and 47
you've won one playoff game you haven't
gone into
deep into the playoffs one time in five
years so you're asking yourself this
question
what is that coach worth
mike my calculations are and you would
probably know this better than i
there are eight coaches one quarter of
the coaches in the nfl right now who
make eight million dollars or more per
year
including john harbaugh who i think is
on the lower end right around 8 million
so if you look at long term
what john harbaugh would want i think he
would want to say okay listen
i i just see pete carroll got whatever
he got we've seen reports it's around 11
million a year uh i mean i i would like
to get at least that if we're talking
about signing here long term and again
mike
this stuff is all pravda we don't know
the real stuff in here but what i'm
saying is if you're john harbaugh i'm
just making this point
if you're not getting paid in the 11
plus million region
why not just coach it out in 2019 say
look i'm happy to stay
why not if you're john harbaugh why not
be kirk cousins
why not just say hey
i'm gonna i'm gonna be what joe flacco
was in 2012 or 13 whatever year that was
and i'm gonna i'm gonna have faith in
myself i'm gonna gamble on myself and at
the end of that they won a super bowl
joe flacco got his 20 million dollar a
year contract and now you look at john
harbaugh
why not do that
that's exactly the way i'd play it if i
were him
and peter here's what's so amazing about
the nfl coaching industry no one ever
does that and i don't know whether they
they just cling to the bird in the hand
they don't want to take the chance that
they're going to become a free agent and
there's not going to be a team out there
that signs them but harbaugh has seen
and heard enough this year when it
looked like he might get run off by the
ravens they were going to line up at the
door to hire john harbaugh so he knows i
come back for that one more year i'm
going to be at the top of the a list and
i will be able to go anywhere i want
assuming there's a vacancy and maybe
there'll be vacancies that otherwise
wouldn't have been there if harbaugh's
in play but i agree with you coaches
should treat themselves like free agents
treat themselves they don't and maybe if
harbaugh does it that'll be the
beginning of a trend where coaches say i
don't want your contract extension i
want to become a free agent because i
have confidence that someone else is
going to pay me a lot more than you ever
would and and i still think there's a
chance that someone tries to finagle
harbaugh now although it's not easy to
do because first you got to fire your
coach then you got to do your normal
coaching search including compliance
with the rooney rule and then at some
point you make the formal contact with
the ravens and try to work out what the
compensation would be assuming you can
even convince harbaugh to come join your
team now a lot of that stuff's going to
get done behind the scenes ahead of time
but i thought it was very compelling
when you pointed out on monday that john
harbaugh there's a real chance he
doesn't accept an extension from the
ravens i think it definitely puts him in
play to walk away after next year and it
has to make the ravens think twice
before they say we want a john gruden
package this year because they're
looking at the reality of getting
nothing for him a year from now
i think the biggest thing is if if i
were the ravens look i would want john
harbaugh i think he's one of the top
five coaches in the nfl i understand
that they haven't won in the last five
years that's the way life goes sometimes
they make the bold decision this year it
forced slightly to go with lamar jackson
but now to stick with him
uh
and and and i think if you look at the
scenario that they're in right now
john harbaugh has to really like the
direction of his team going forward
they've got a different offense that
everybody's going to have to go to
school on to try to stop and
with so many of these young defensive
stars
looming on this team
and and with terrell suggs playing like
he's 25 not 35 or whatever he is
uh this is a really interesting team
in 2019
one of the teams that
in the off season will be studied
heavily on both sides of the ball to see
they're doing it a different way is that
a smart way is it a sustainable way and
so if i'm john harbaugh mike i i know
this is going to sound strange but
even if a cleveland or green bay came
after him and and tried to offer
compensation for him and they could work
it out
if i were him i might want to stay in
baltimore that is i i just think it's a
fascinating story
here's the key
he can get with one of these other teams
not with the packers of the browns but
he could get with the dolphins something
he doesn't have and will never have in
baltimore and that is control adam gase
currently runs everything in miami and i
assume that if steven ross would end up
making this move and being successful
harbaugh gets the keys to the
organization if that's something he
wants he's only going to get it in a
place like miami or another team that
would be willing to hand everything over
to him and maybe at this point in his
career he wants to give that a try who
knows but i think that would be a factor
in this as well we're going to take one
negative thing there mike mike the one
negative thing there no quarterback
and the and the other places have
quarterbacks and he probably has his
quarterback in baltimore you can sign
joe flacco and miami i'm just kidding
all right i don't know that joe flacco
would be interested in her union with
john harbaugh after the way things went
down this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports